right ladies and gentlemen welcome
today's cnr first of all can you get the
public on youtube or whatever that's all
done so i welcome members of the public
as well
um
i don't want to apologize for absence
i've had mom
nobody's had any we've got
[Music]
right item two public contributions
i've had none
and i love you good job we can move on
declarations of interest
those members who have an interest in an
item need to declare i say this for the
benefit of the members of the public
but when it comes to things like budgets
and capsule that we're all caught up in
it
and we are all permitted to speak
item four agreement in the agenda
between parts one and two we've got
nothing that indicates a part two item
so that means that the public will be
able to listen to everything
i can find urgent matters of information
i've not heard of anything urgent so we
can move on proper
to item six which is the budget for next
year
the medium term strategy
so
section 151 officer
that's the boss man on finance will deal
with this one
[Music]
so what will i cover in the presentation
of the budget 2022-23 the median7
financial strategy
and so first off i'll recap when we're
basically this time last year
i'll give a brief refresher on the
sources of the council's finances
i'll go through the
2022-25 settlement from central
government
i'll go through some non-settlement
related emerging financial pressures
i'll go through the key assumptions and
risks i've identified in violating the
median term financial strategy
and i'll sum up and say what does all
this mean to the revenue wouldn't
i won't actually go through the capital
my colleague peter hudson will go
through a capital report separately
uh so i'll summarize everything what
that means to them in term financial
strategy and then obviously we finish
with recommendations and next steps can
i have the next slide
so this is a recap where we were this
time last year
so in february of 2021 we predicted a
surplus let's say a deficit for 22 23
coming back into modest surplus for 22
25 25 26
and to fund those uh deficits that we
projected we're going to use some
winners from our transitional
transitioning government funding reserve
and as you can see that's predicting at
the end of 25 26 we actually have 800
000 pounds left in our transitioning
government fund result to sum up we were
going to dip into the building society
account to balance the budgets but we
still have a reasonably healthy balance
left in the transition of government
funding to the building side to
questline please
okay i think i hammered on this every
year and maybe
some apologies for doing it but anyway
here goes and just summarize what the
source is about finance does a council
we obviously get council tax we keep a
portion of business rates where fees and
charges and central government run and
essentially the chart that you can see
there the right-hand side is the central
government grant as you can see that's a
declining proportion
of our income
and fees and charges is actually our
biggest um
element of income to the council so on
there's a long-term
decline it's proportionate about money
that comes from central government grant
that's likely firstly
um it's our name on the bill so when the
bills go out it says sorry to descript
council
however the vast majority of council tax
we collect is not on behalf of torres
district council it's on behalf of
preceptors democrat county council devin
coleman police
our town and parish council which i
think about 56 of them raised a precept
and our share has been in long-term
decline and i'm predicting that our
share the council tax bill 22-23 will be
about point three four percent it's
obviously a prediction because we don't
want the presets as
devon county fire and police are gonna
raise as this at this moment's entire
so there's a little bar chat and pie
chart there and shows that we're just
about eight percent and we're in
long-term and the reason being
is that the
county have had a social care precept so
they've had more than we've had in terms
of inflation the rising to their share
of the council attack the police have
had above um inflation rises in that
reset
councils they have no restriction on
what they can raise through their
recession whilst we're capped at
referendum with this next slide please
personally
so to put that into content so this
little graphic what it's trying to say
is based on
what the county can put up their council
tax up by and what the fire and police
authorities can put up their attacks by
and make an assumption about the town of
paris councils
if the torres mr puppets and council
taxes by its maximum permissible which
is five pound for banking which is equal
to two point nine percent
our five pound is quite a small
compartment as a very small proportion
but the overall bill will go up by which
is the left hand column of coins
so we've made very minimal impacts on
actually the financial liability of our
residents
next slide please
um
obviously
you won't be surprised as to what the
recommendation is based on there is a
legacy as a council if we don't agree to
put the council tax up
because we have a referendum limit if we
don't put councils happening one year we
can't make it good in another year
that year's gone
and we did as a council take advantage
of some countertop freeze grants back
around the 2010-2011-2012
tower
well those grants were non-recurring and
because we're going to put the council
tax up
we can never make good that lost
opportunity and that graphic there shows
how much cumulatively we've lost by not
increasing our council tax and foregoing
the offer of countries grants from
central government and how much on an
annual basis
and we've basically got ball going about
three and a half million pounds which is
basically the
cost of replacing our vehicle fleet the
road equipped recycling fleet that
people see around the streets
and the four hundred thousand annual
income that before going that's
approximately the cost of providing
leisure from 2025-26
so there's a consequence for those
decisions that were made back in the
2010-2000-2012
next slide please
our resources are funding business rates
as a council we retain 40 percent of the
business rates that we collect in the
borough we don't set the business rates
that's set by central government
and central will keep 50 percent the
county nine and then set by one
the one and
normally is that we do keep 100 of all
renewable energy streams where we
provided the planning permission for
that renewable energy scheme to go ahead
and at the moment we get about i think
it's about 585 000 pounds of renewable
energy
which we keep 100
and as i alluded earlier um fees and
charges are actually our biggest source
of income for the council we collect
just over 600 six and a half million in
fees and charges which cover a wide
range of services some of the fees and
charges are statutory you know clearly
planning fees are set by central
government because you've got a choice
where you can put your planning
application into you
which is located
uh overalls are calculated on cost
recovery basis such as land charges
moving more discretionary and the
discretionary fees in chapter is the
most income generation potential uh
parking and garden waste rental earth
councils commercial premises cemeteries
and building control
and the first three are by far the
biggest and parking is the biggest of
the lot
they're the most scope we have next
slide for us
so
let's move on to the
2022-23 provisional settlement
the headline figure you might read in
the papers and the press is essentially
what's provided 3.5 billion extra
funding to councils which is an increase
of over 4 in real terms to the core
spending power the government will
always refer to core spending power of
councils
so what is the core spending power well
it's a combination of factors based
grants direct from government which
revenue support rural service delivery
ground lower tier service the services
run new homes bonus and it's also
council tax income and retained business
rate increment
and in central government's assessment
of core spending power for councils they
assume that council tax will be
increased up to the referendum limits
and they also make some underlying
assumptions about how
much the council tax base of the council
will grow and it's roughly one and a
half percent each year they assume the
growth of a number of properties that
become liable for council tax and that's
why those first thing
so
what settlements have we had at storage
um
not great would be this implant
so we've seen a growth in our core
spending power
of 1.1
the average for share districts across
the um
country and my eyesight is that i don't
have to say around 4.3
if you look at the yellow or orange bar
going across that's what inflation was
in november uh cpi was 5.17 it's
actually since i did this slide we've
got december speak it's actually 5.4
so clearly we've had a below inflation
settlement from central government
um
i'm going to have the next slide for
these
customers and then
so again
just two other slides for comparison
obviously we're still
1.1 the second one compares ourselves
with the south west
which is six by four percent so we're
not doing very well being when compared
to the southwest
so the southwest is in the blue so it's
two things in blue the one on the left
is torrent to one towards that side it's
the southwest
and if you compare us to a bit
um deprivation group which is
we are one by one and they are
seven percent
so basically by any metrics that has not
been a good settlement atari's district
council
without the next five months
um so what's emerged since we're getting
the settlement for the time being since
i sat here before you in january
february of last year
well we've had emerging financial
pressures being leisure
um
staff salaries and i'm going to say that
that's not necessarily going to go into
the staff but it's like employers ni
contributions have gone up we're
anticipating an increase in the
employer's pension contribution
and also
we underestimated what the pay award
would be for local authority employees
the government had announced that
there'd be
zero percent for anybody under twenty
four thousand and two hundred and fifty
pounds
per annum for anybody under twenty four
thousand that's current offers one point
seven five percent so we've got a short
fall in our budget because of the pay
award
and the other factors
uh
putting extra money into the vehicle
replacement
and the cost of residual tipping at
deepmore in torrington
so what have been the emerging savings
that have come since this time last year
business rate income but that is i'll
cut the caveat of that that's an
assumption on renewables that get the
gates some considerable time in the
future
planning income and i'll come to this
later in the presentation planning for
last two years i've seen unprecedented
levels of demand
so i've increa having
increased the target for planning and
i'll come to the risk factor and
associate that later
um because it's vacation extending the
hours that the charging period for
access to northern boroughs that's been
a benefit to us
and the last one as an emerging saving
is not really a savings such as maybe a
reflection of the world i've increased
our vacancy target and that reflects the
difficulty counts it has a battery
recruit stuff so
if they aim play leads and we're trying
to improve some ram difficulty in
recruiting replacement staff so
vacancies occur where there's a
frontline service like richard's asari
operations we get agencies staffing
straight away but certain jobs
we don't get agencies straight in
because you know the person needs to be
trained up or have the necessary
experience so next slide please
so
leisure that represents the biggest
revenue pressure to the council and the
median term financial strategy assumes
that the cost of providing leisure will
fall to circa 450 000 by the year
2025-26
income for leisure he's not anticipated
to return to pre-pandemic levels until
24-25
just summarizing there some of the
staffing issues after the payer wallet
the increase in employees national
insurance
projected uh increases in employers
pension contributions and with inflation
being so high future pay awards
the vehicles um we've got we set aside
money every year into a vehicle
replacement yeah reserves
and when we come to replace the runway
quickly that's the recycling plate that
you see
and when that's due to the replacement
it's 25 26 we will have enough money in
reserve
to
pay for that fleet will happen when you
set aside however if we carry on point
when the rate we're putting away now
when we come to replace that fleet in
2032 by the shortfall of 3 million
so prudently we need to start putting
increasing our contributions into the
reserves not to meet the replacements of
25 26 but to do the replacement since
2032
and i've already mentioned the tipping
fees that's like this
so
the savings potential income and
potential savings planning income i'll
come on to a slide later on northern
borrows the access the charging for
longer
the vacancy target which isn't a good
news story really the increasing debate
attention just really is reflecting the
difficult environment we're currently in
and business rates but to
be aware of the business rates that does
assume future
income for renewable energy streams some
years into the future
just like this
so what my key assumptions
i've assumed that the council tax will
increase by up to the referendum limit
for the duration of the median term
financial scrap so every year we will
put the council tax upon by the
allowable referendum
i've assumed that leisure income will
return to pre-pandemic levels by 2425
and that the cost of providing leisure
will be circle 450 000 pound per year by
2526
i've assumed that pay awards over the
life of the medium term financial
strategy will be two percent per annum
and that's a challenge at the moment
with inflation being so high
i've assumed that employers pension
contributions will rise by 1.25 from 23
to 24. that's been indicated by the debt
and pension service they wouldn't be a
proven figure to set aside
the importance of numbers i make no
assumption about any future central
government review of local authority
funding what used to be called the first
monday review
i've just assumed what we've got
goes forward to the best of my knowledge
and make no assumption about whether
we'll be a winner or a loser under any
review of central government grants
i've also assumed that planning income
will be 250 000 higher than the budget
that we currently have over the life of
the medium financial strategy and that
will generate their increased income
from northern boroughs of 120 000 pounds
a year going forward next slide
libraries
so just to give some context about the
difficulties of
forecasting the further you go into the
future
there's a chart showing our planning
income
and as you can see from year 1617
to 19 to enter it didn't move very much
it hovered
around the 600 000 mark
and the last two years we've basically
doubled that in each year
so what should the planning income
budget be for next year
i i don't i don't really know but i've
assumed an increase of 250 000 pounds
so but there's the risk
you know are we in a bubble that's going
to burst or is this
going to last longer
next slide please
a bit of a messy slide but basically
what i'm trying to show here what's the
impact if we don't increase the council
tax
and essentially what happens we don't
increase the council tax for one year
net this year 2020 to 23.
we never return to balanced position
the deficit will always have a deficit
we kept won't go away from that and the
slide at the bottom indicator we'd
actually have to use another 630
thousand pounds from reserve reserves
over that period to balance
that's five years
so
i'm looking maybe some counsellors have
been mentioned before why all the doom
and gloom don't we always have a surplus
i can't deny i've reported to you in the
last couple of years surpluses
so why did he even bloom we also had a
surplus
well for the last two years there's two
big factors of why i'm very surprised
and being honest we've had a surplus
covered by the pandemic
and the government has given us grant to
administer business support grants and
track and trace payments
and largely that additional workload has
been absorbed from the existing results
no exclusive we have had some
significant additional costs because of
it
but largely there's been a financial
windfall it's been a
terrible for the country it's been a
financial
source for the windfarm
and the other big battle players have
already alluded to planning income
i've had a budget just over half a
million
550 000 and we've been getting over a
million million too in planning income
so they're the two reason primary
reasons is all the factors as well
as to why over the last two years well
i'm not predicting getting any kobe
support ground from central government
next year
i'm already assuming i'm increasing my
budget for planning income
by 250 thousand maybe have been too
proven
but that's why
if not predicted to without a surplus in
2021 and it's in a very significant
surface for the current financial year
the financial position doesn't look
particularly healthy less likely
so
what does it all mean
so
so you've got the chances we see the red
ones this is where we were this time
last year so we had we've predicted a
deficit for 2022-23 we're predicting
deficit for 2023-24
and we're predicting getting back into
the circus and 24-25 and a little bit
more being 25-26
i'm not predicting bigger deficits
between 22 23 23 24 24 25
not getting back into service in 25-26
and essentially
just
breaking even in 26 27 um at a level
that's barely noticed on the child you
can't actually see it it's just such a
small figure
and that's assumes that leisure comes
back within
a cost angle over 450
also what does that mean then to the
transitioning government fundraising
this is our building society account
that we use to balance the books when
we've got deficits
and we're predicting that we'll start
at 1.718 million
and we're going to use
one point you can say 1.43 million but
that over the course of the years and
financial strategy to balance so we're
going to be using
over three quarters of our building
society account to balance the books
yeah some might say he's selling the
family silver but basically we're
dipping into our reserves to balance the
books
because of the wrong prediction over the
mediator financial strategy of next
slide please
so here's the recommendations
so the first recommendation is that we
increased the council tax band for vandy
by five pound which is two point nine
percent from 173
66 to 170 if i'm 66
then our net revenue budget asked for
the report is 7.93
the contributions to reserves as
outlined in the report 11.4 have
approved and perhaps maybe almost more
importantly that a working group this
establishment is established the
membership to be determined by full
council which will recharge we've
reported back to cnl with options for
bringing the council's finances back
into balance
i also asked you to note
the robustness of the budgets as i set
out in section 13 and also the
assumptions
and forecasts about
and the risks associated with my fair
productions of the research financial
strategy
to take any questions you may have
oh the house councilor brenton was the
first one i saw
uh yes david uh how does this fit in
with uh your predictions fit in with the
national picture especially amongst the
shire counties are we
where eventually we sit in
the statistics from
[Music]
i've already sat down with council
hudson on this particular issue
we need to grant something from lg
futures and a professional organization
that look at local government financing
um so i
can tell you that west desert
where we are 1.1
in our comprehensive spending power
they're 4.6
i can't tell you every local authority
because not every local folks are
subscribed to the service
okay
so
all i can say is when is it
international and nationally
if you go back to those slides
i mean the national picture to put it
simply is if you have social
services responsibilities
you've had above inflation
increases in your
core spending power
okay however
you've probably got above inflation
pressures in your social services
so i'm not necessarily
addressing i'm not sure i'd want
necessity the county then encounters
section one 1 500 are facing their
challenges i might have
what would appear on the superficially a
good
settlement but i've got
significant pressures
but the point i'm making is really the
district councils then
are pretty much all suffering the same
in terms of uh
we're not that much of a drift
uh no you go back to the next slide then
because you won back
well the average bashar district was 4.6
and we're 1.1 so i'd say we're three
times worse than north shore districts
yeah
yeah on this particular point steve i
think that was the one something um
thanks thanks chad
and it's just worth noting at this at
this point uh we did brief our mp on
friday uh friday afternoon
um david b has challenged the department
of our figures to to get them to look
into it a bit more
detail
for members who have been around for a
long long time you know the the
financial the government local
government finance system has been
tinkered around with um successively and
so it is hugely complicated and uh sir
jeffrey cox is going to take it up with
uh michael on our behalf and he
indicated would contact him shortly
so it seems little recognition of the
deprivation of this district then really
in terms of its reflection on those
central government support
[Music]
yes clearly because people in our
deprivation group their average is
seven percent and we're one point one
right
thank you
councillor christine yeah thank you can
i ask a couple of questions about
page 15 the table which i think is the
main
favorite of the whole report
um
[Music]
i'm intrigued to see that uh our
business rates and renewables by
25 you're forecasting to be our third
largest income which is interesting um
but can we ask about the revised
assumptions regarding the new homes
bonus because i thought new home phones
is being phased out and yet you're
saying it's going to stay the same for
the next three years well
it will be
that's what's the same that's replaced
by
a
successor to it which has been indicated
over the last three years
i'd assumed
i've probably been overly prudent that
would get no new homes bonus
the general thing is now it will be
replaced in some guys and i've made an
assumption that the minimum we will get
will be
the figures i've indicated which is
quite a long figure given that we used
to get two million pounds a year from
being on promise they've been being
honest i don't i don't know all i know
is that it is keeps getting mentioned
that they will replace the system of
leave on bonus and every year it gets
extended one year this is a one year
salary from central government
you know
my hands are somewhat tired because i
don't know what they're going to do
after that
but my best guess is there will be a
replacement for newborn boneless no
practically but they could be proven to
what we may get from that
um you're probably aware as inspector
orders are that um new home is quite
often quoted as a sort of bribe from the
government to build more houses
uh it doesn't go down well with a lot of
people because i'm just intrigued can
you tell us when we when you you hear
about it what this new thing is going to
be because
it wasn't
terribly popular with the public i mean
there was a precessor which was called
planning delivery grants
it could be something related to the
planning
applications that get approved
right and can i just go back to the um
the council tax income
[Music]
in torres we if you look at our own
figures
one in fourteen houses are either second
homes or holidays in torres and that's
the ones we know about
um is there any scope for us to increase
the business rates or the council tax on
second homes to three hundred percent
well we can't uh we can't influence the
business rates right i'm not too sure
the empty entry i'd have to
yeah so david's right so um internal
scrutiny made a recommendation some
years ago to increase to the maximum
level council tax on second home
properties
which has already been put in place so
there's no other room for maneuver on
that front
can i go back to something that steve
said earlier then about
uh you saw rmp
last week
is this come up at all this the whole
business rates
scheme you know they're all going into
businesses now they're not staying as
counterpart we're losing quite a lot of
money was that brought up
yes
is he going to do anything about it he's
going to bring it up to parliament or
um
so it's been brought up by lots of
different
authorities it's been brought up by the
lga so there is
lots of work being
done on eggs and there are some changes
coming into place from the first of
april
making it
a more robust process for
holiday let properties to actually
improve advertising for 70 days i think
70
140 days so it's increased from 70 to
140 days so there are
already moves a foot or moves being put
in place
and that's done off the tangent slightly
but it is about our council tax
um
advertising doesn't prove
that you've actually left the place you
can advertise it and then just tell
everyone oh sorry it's already booked
and just not leave it um
is there going to be any any check on
actually
um the number of times it's used rather
than just advertised
um it's it's it's not for the district
council that's the valuation of this
agency and it's been assigned to them so
it's part of it will need to be part of
their process not ours they determine
whether properties on the business rate
register or council tax register not the
district council
do we know how many
um
is in how many of these new businesses
have been set up
i wouldn't be able to pick up something
i don't know how much we're losing then
well
if i'm being honest christy it's unclear
whether in the realm we would have lost
money the reason being is we've retained
50 percent of business rates however
because of the way small business rate
relief works
in reality we get 65 of that 40
but that in some instances might be more
than the council tax it may not have to
be a loss of income to the council
take some
statistical analysis
of some magnitude to actually work that
one out and be perfectly honest with you
you know i mean i'm not sure these
reports are easily extracted from our
council system to do this
thank you my gut feeling transfer
christie is that the
bulk of these sort of things you're
looking at are on the small business
right
councillor
yes i'd just like to endorse what our
chief exec
shared with you about our meeting with
um
sir jeffrey
uh we did express very strongly our
disappointment which i note in the
recommendations of the report of our
settlement of 1.1
and we went through every strand that we
were aware of that might have been
considered in the
formula for calculating this
and challenged virtually all of them
and the issue of second homes holiday
lets
and the impact that was having on our
tax base
was emphasized also we emphasized the
fact that like many other authorities
the disappointment that it's only a
one-year settlement that it makes life
even more complex for planning for the
future when we're planning a medium-term
strategy for our authorities
so i think he
was under
no
illusion about how dissatisfied we were
with this and we really did strongly uh
endorse the communications that our
section 151 officer has had
asking for an explanation and that we
wanted some answers so um we're not
resting on our laurels here we are
challenging this on your behalf
thank you
council of laws
thank you for that presentation it was
quite
mind
mind-blowing
how do you sleep at night
i wonder right so just to go back to the
simplistic thing here
um the band
increased by five pounds
which will no doubt be agreed this year
which historically every four years we
don't even do as we should
in your formal plan
are you allowed
[Music]
oh come on
well if members decide not to put the
council tax up before the next district
election the impact will be as per that
slide where everything moved on one year
so essentially your fargo
140 000 pounds which you'll never get
back
and that'll mean there will
be a worse financial position basically
there will be a minute to remember the
decision
that my responsibility session will find
officer one
the consequences of that decision and
that slide
is showing you the consequence of that
decision that we'll
if we do it next year for 2022-23 we did
that input the council attack so
over the next four years up to 25 26
we'd
eat in an additional 600 foot additional
630 thousand ounces of our transitioning
government funded essentially the
building started out but the absolute
saturday can't be overdrawn
and
[Music]
two twenty three
start did you approve the budget as of
today essential
and my last one is the uh leisure
services
where obviously
there's gonna be a hiccup but initially
there's going to be a lot of money
needing to bring themselves
back up
the buildings back up
well we set aside
771 000 from the 2020
one
2021 service with surplus we set aside
771 000 into a
leisure reserve 250 000 for mobilization
and the balance bar exactly the worst
that you indicated council lost uh we
won't spend the full 250 000 on the
mobilization so there is a little bit
extra available for the
fabric shall we say of the leicester
census
i wish that was
um
i'm quite happy to
move this support this
recommendation but one
small question i could ask please and
that is the the uh 120 000 increase on
northern boroughs
with all the stakeholders from the
visitors that we've had over the last
couple of years that's you know brought
extra income into that into the air and
clearly there's also
um quite a burden which is falling on
the the local
uh users of november's in other words
local people
with the exception of those northern
uh members and all the residents that
are eligible to get a free bearish pass
i i just wonder
is it time or is is there
is there an opportunity to actually
extend that concession to tourist rate
players rather than just those in the
ancient manner of normal because clearly
dawn virus is funded entirely by
uh
by tauruses or council coffers
[Music]
would change accordingly
[Music]
when i went and played golf but um
yesterday
i was quite busy getting older on the
third and the 17th holes i suspect
majority of that traffic was local
so
[Music]
i think what i'm trying to make is that
you know clearly
some people would get a free balance
pass on tourists and others don't in
other words if you don't live in the
ancient manner
you can't even qualify for it and i
think you know the fact that you know
this porridge money that's being spent
to
maintain and do works on the purpose it
seems only fair if it's possible to look
into what it would cost
to extend that scheme
across here i mean it's a limited number
that northern offers not everyone that
normally can get it but it could be also
a limited number that was available to
the rest of the tourist residents who
could apply on a first-come first-served
basis
uh thanks chet um so obviously
recommendation d
uh in the report um suggests setting up
a working group as david's literature we
haven't got any of those figures or
information to hand today but there's a
working group to be established subject
to
uh approval and that working group can
look into things additional in kennel
and all those kinds of things at later
stage
council
council laws my god
that money is actually for loss of
grazing
takes place
[Music]
yeah
it brings in a lot of money i think it
could bring in more with an extension to
the hours um
i think look at this
chancellor point of view and not a ward
member we sell ourselves short we could
be starting charging at eight o'clock in
the morning we could be locals to walk
onto the horoscope
and there are a vast number of cars that
are there early in the morning and into
the evening we stopped charging
yesterday
thank you chair
councillor leather
thank you thank you chad because i'm not
a member of this commitment but just to
pick up on councillor buffett's wrong
nobody has a free pass for the boroughs
but not them they pay for them
we get 1200 as council laws and said in
compensation for loss of grazing
and
they're they're only
available to people in the old parish of
northern itself it's not westward or
apple
which all comes only
getting back to the report that david's
presenting then
as usual it's a very good report and
i've read it all through
i just
mentioned it seems to me that the 1.1
provisional settlement
is kind of a punishment really for being
fiscally proven this council has always
been and sometimes i've said perhaps too
prudent
proved to be
a good policy and a good
way to work over the years and i just
have this awful suspicion that this 1.1
provision settlement is because
we've managed our finances so well
and it's a shame that but what i would
like to ask david about the council
collects the collection rate council tax
collection rate the target for the last
financial year was 97.45
then we've it's dropped to 97.1
um
for the next financial year we're
setting it at 98
my question really is
what in cash terms
i haven't got the mental gymnastics to
do all those calculations just in the
head just at the normal council level
but to put in
perspective of course we're only 8.5
of the council tax
um and actually
in this budget we've there's a surplus
on the collection from the council tax
even at that collection rate
what you actually find in reality you
have an in-year collection very say 97
[Music]
but the actual
cumulative collection rate because we
collect council tax this year we'll be
collecting council tax before five years
ago for people in arrangements
we get we ultimately get the vast
majority of the overwhelming majority
council taxes actually collected it's
very very little that's actually really
written off they've been treated but
it's not just when she's not the gender
people who've got ibas
it's ultimately our partners
you know left to borrow so to speak and
we can't trace them
so
the collection rate is actually
i think we've had issues this year
because i've started
i know the team at the moment runs a
great deal of pressure you know one
thing you can do is you can
maybe not do as much on the recovery to
try and process the day-to-day change of
circumstances
um
it's been more challenging i'd say our
collection rate in the last two years it
has been before but we have a very high
collection
and it reflects the kind of borough that
we are we don't have live students in
some of the other cities and places like
that where it's very transgender
population
thank you steve did you want to come in
right um
[Music]
there was someone who tried caught their
eye earlier counselor laws i think was
it yeah yeah
okay we'll move on let's look at whose
hands are up counselor lock
yeah i mean clearly we you know exactly
very excellent report
and i will leave all the
precise details to the experts i mean
the options that we've given on page at
the 21
um
we've got to increase the fees and
charges in my opinion
we cannot afford to reduce the level of
management services and i think the only
option that's open to us really is to
either stop or reduce this residue
services
um
we've got very i mean the figures in
respect to all the
less
active torridge and mind-boggling in my
opinion and that's something that we've
got to keep an eye on and carefully
one point with regard to the putting up
the council tax i think david is saying
is in his report that once you decide
not to put it up you could never get
that revenue back so i think you know
we've got no option but i'm afraid to
put the council tax up by five pounds
and i totally agree with council
hodgson's um
comments on page 23 so i would support
the recommendations
so that's a second big
capture push please prepare yeah thank
you
councillor brenton
thank you um
i think one of the reasons in the past
why councillors didn't support increases
was that we didn't really have a very
robust hardship fund uh
reservoir we don't have any figures here
today on that but i presume the last 12
months we've had uh
increase um
demand on that hardship fund is
is that going to increase that budget
for the hardship and on the criteria of
being changed at all because that is a
critical one
i think it's been a bit of an unusual
year because we've had the household um
is it called the household fund place
downstairs
so we've actually
it sounds silly advanced felt like we've
been um
a sub office of the dwp processing
household
uh crisis payments um and lady works for
me he's part payroll she basically do
her
extra hours just delivering that uh i
think we'll top out about
well over 130 000 pounds this year maybe
even more by the time it's done we do
have a council attached hardship
funds available
i don't know how much they've been
utilized if i'm honest it's probably
more people have gone for this
of the last 12 20 months the household
hardship fund because you get more
direct payments you're not just getting
some relief on your council terms you're
getting your fuel bill paid or
i think that is a factor which will
stress on people's minds tonight before
council is to
you know as long as we're not getting uh
people slipping through the net if we
like
being in real hardship as a result of
increasing council tax
thank you uh come to benjamin that the
fence you know you're referring to is
linked to the council tax support scheme
um which is approved at full coverage at
the last full council meeting um but
also approved that the working group
reconvened to look at the the scheme and
everything around the scheme that they
were bringing
back proposals
for 23 24.
thank you
right i don't think i've got anyone oh
counselor
your vice chair is waving frantically
give me digging ribs
so i just want to say thank you today
with very prudent um budgeting
um
and you're very good at your job and
every single year for the past 10 years
i've sat here and listened to
a sob story about how awful everything's
gonna be and we need to
take the money from everyone because we
need it we're not going to survive
without it we always do
we always get by somehow
and now more than ever
i am stand i'm gonna stand here i'll sit
here and represent the taxpayer
because
everything is going up
it is not on
people will not be able to afford it
and frankly the council will survive
inevitably we have to make cuts
inevitably fees and charges go up
everything is going up this is the one
thing
that i can vote on
and stand up to my taxpayer and say
actually
i said no
because the rest of the people in this
room appear to be
yeah okay let's lie down roll over and
it's very prudent but frankly
the government
need to give us more money
not the taxpayer ultimately it's a big
old circle and they the government get
the money off the taxpayer anyway but
i'm not going to vote in favor of
putting the preceptor or the the um
council tax up
to to benefit this council it's the easy
option and this council will get through
so i will not
but thank you david it's great
so james i'm sorry
i've got to say i can't agree with that
um we didn't put the council tax up back
in 2014 wasn't it and we've been going
backwards since in terms of our revenue
our proportion is what 10 pence a week
or something and we're about 8.4 percent
of the council yes
so it is measurable what we're doing but
we are safeguarded that we are providing
the services people want
and
if we don't then we've got to start
looking at what we can that could be
public toilets it could be anything
that's discretionary and it's the real
world i'm afraid none of us won't put
tax up but
you have to be realistic and we have to
have a budget and we did make it very
clear to jeffrey hopps on providing that
we are suffering because of this 1.1
session
it is possible that because we've been
proven in the past and jeffrey did raise
that actually and said you know
you've balanced the books well for years
what's the problem no well the problem
though is that we are not keeping up
with inflation and i've always told my
parish council for the 40 years i've
been involved is if you don't match
inflation you're going backwards
and you know you can only go backwards
if you cut things and as the leader of
council
i'm not prepared to allow that to happen
and we still need to go forward we've
got projects we need to do
we need to provide the leisure services
we need to do all that sort of work
what will be our proportion is only 10 p
a week and maybe you just can't be
realistic
thank you chad
thank you right
can i come back
i just have to say that yes keeping pace
with inflation is vital but how many
residents within our community
how much of their income doesn't keep
pace with inflation
right well i'm going to move this on now
i've got
page 23 i've got
oh
bright pumping speed i just wanted to
highlight that this year's the first
year the the average wage in the uk has
gone down
[Music]
right we've got a recommendation on item
15 on page 23 proposed in its entirety
by councillor bushby
seconded by councillor locke i'm going
to put this to the vote now it needs a
recorded vote
so we hand it over
to
[Music]
against councillor hicks okay
councillor hudson or
councillor harley four
councillor james four
council indoors four
councillor knock four
that's seven four
three against one abstention
thank you
right good debate interesting
we now move on to
item seven
capital program
going to be take this i think to be
taken i guess by peter hudson
oh steve's going to introduce
uh thanks chair um you're just going to
run through
another presentation as david's just
done with you
i thought it'd just be useful just to
set a little bit of the the background
as there's been a quite a couple of
questions being raised over the last
couple of days around the pinned scoring
the paid process and the like so it's
probably worthwhile just
as that's an intrinsic part of the
report or the score in there on one of
the pages as well so
um obviously in order to get to this
stage
officers have put together
business cases evaluation forms
details in
[Music]
in a
document a project initiation
document
obviously is good practice because you
need to have information about what the
project is about what is going to
deliver how it fits in with your
strategic plans uh how it determines
value for money are the health and
safety risks is external funding so all
of those factors
are considered in the in the documents
obviously the documents are not attached
to your report um
a clear reason for not doing that many
of these projects have to go out for a
procurement exercise so you wouldn't
necessarily want to know all the
prospective tenderers all the details of
your project before they before they
submit the bid
so we used to have this process in place
a number of years ago and it was due for
a refresh so your internal our internal
overview scrutiny committee set up a
working group uh during the summer of
2021
and uh with the help of peter and david
and reported back to the scrutiny
committee uh from that task and finished
group back in september 2021.
so the the scrutiny committee uh
following recommendations from the task
and finish group
approved the
project initiation document which as i
said set out all detail in all the
backgrounds of the projects how they
would fit in with a strategic plan and
so forth
so each of the four core elements of the
project
its deliverability its deliverable
delivery of value for many
its
association or commitment to the
strategic plan and its funding are all
separately scored uh they're
individually scored by myself
david hayes section one by one officer
and the leader of the council
scored out of a hundred
so each of the sections has 24 points
and you'll see the scores
in your report for each of the projects
that have been submitted the threshold
of 65
was again a recommendation by internal
overview scrutiny and that's a
recommendation based on those individual
projects scoring out of a hundred um you
know really giving some good value uh
for the use of the council's resources
they're not binding so those scores
aren't binding i know this is red line
drawn in your report but that clearly
doesn't bind members to deciding below
or above that line for including
projects in the capital program
um such as just really good practice our
external auditors when they look at our
budget process the process for
delivering projects uh look at these
documents and obviously it's best
practice good practice to have something
uh tangible and robust that sits behind
it so they can uh clearly
report on how the council's operating
its budget how it's operated strategic
plan and its best use and money for many
use of our resources so sure that we've
just been used useful for members to
understand some of that background
before peter
so i'm just going to run through the
capture program and the update plans for
next year so
currently we've got the current capital
programme and we're going to update it
for the next five years
this is updating the forecasts and spend
the spend on the receipts we're getting
we'll start updating for inflation on
the vehicle programme and inflation on
build costs and tender price on a lot of
the other larger projects
um then we're going to have a look at
the new mids which steve's just talked
through the process um
pinterest has been submitted but we've
also got some future ones coming in
um such as leisure and the pressure
sorry thank you speaker
so we've also got um some
bigger pressures from leisure as well
coming on and also
the move um which is coming in the
future on vehicles and moves to electric
that'll
[Music]
come around as a part of that um from
that we'll see that there's um a gap or
a shortfall um the vehicle program which
david's already alluded to a little bit
um be updated long term
and
then we're also going to look at the
general program and some
additional future pressures
so this is the capital programs we
started in um which was approved by full
council last february um
that came to 24 million pounds
and
we had a slight surplus of 142 000
and from there we've adjusted it for
um
adjustments to the funding this is
additional receipts from right to buys
and we've also adjusted um surpluses
from um
last year
and uh contributions from new home bonus
we've also extended the disabled
facilities grant um
out by a few extra
to the full five years and extended the
whole program by an extra year
when we
when we put all that through we actually
uh increased our surplus to 2.6 million
we then looked at updating the vehicle
program so it increased it by
for inflation there was already some
inflation built in but um as everyone
was aware inflation is um
getting bigger and bigger
we've also extended the vehicle program
out for the full five years
and that reduces the our surplus to 2.3
million
[Music]
um so
so that's where we're on
at this point so then we really needed
to look at the inflation
so this is um building cost inflation on
most of the larger projects so this is
just a extract from bricks
so this is showing that material prices
have got rising almost 17 percent um
practices as of october last year and
the forecaster continued rising you know
so the next few years adding another
five percent
um building costs were nine percent
higher in october than the previous year
and you can see by the table that
there's just a general trend
to increase
the increase in due to inflation
so from using this as a rough guide and
sitting down with the property manager i
reviewed the current program so we
identified 12 projects and areas which
are impacted by this
and these projects add up to about 10
million pounds and that includes the new
environmental center which equates
an average inflation of about 10 percent
that has
actually 977 000 pounds of additional
costs
so
we adjust our capital program for that
that reduces our current our surplus to
1.4 million
so then so here we are starting with the
1.4 million surplus then these are all
the new kids which have been submitted
this
um during the year
and so we've got um criminal lane
refurbishment we've got uh digitization
of the revenue revenue benefits service
we've got the disabled access pathways
of cats down
i've got grounds maintenance equipment
which has
already been improved um
council over the course server we've got
torrent and penny markets we've got
sandy near road um improvements
um we've got uh electric vans for
maintenance electric mounts for car
parks we've got victoria park player and
we've also got fish stock
adding all those pits and so there's
some small amounts of funding on some of
them and this reduces our surplus to
just under 400 000 pounds
so then in the next step next page thank
you um so then
what we haven't currently got
included
and that's what is the leisure and
vehicles moving to electric so
so here you can see that you've got
finish an initial assessment of around
600 grand required for actual
maintenance to bring the sites back up
to use
um and in addition
we estimate about require about 60 grand
per site
for ongoing
capital requirements now we currently
have 350 000 already in the capital
programme
um
this 60 percent per year
um which would seem quite prudent um
then this answering an extra 900 000
onto the program uh we can now also book
521 000 um
which has been which is what dave was
alluding to early which is currently in
the leisure reserve for such costs so
that reduces it so that funds some of it
uh in addition to that we've got um
electric the move to electric vehicles
which will be covering over the next few
years uh they're currently two pins
within
which have been submitted within this
which is the additional cost of
upgrading four vans to electric
over the traditional cost
and then we've also taken the
rest of our small bands which is around
24 of them
and looked at when they're likely to be
replaced and estimated sort of an
additional cost for them um being quite
prudent
would be quite optimistic
um that the cost of moving to electric
will reduce significantly in the coming
years that adds an extra 300 grand um so
that actually moves us from a surface of
400 grams to a short full of 300.
so from here this time david alluded to
the vehicle program
in his presentation so this is actually
saying if that's 300 grand
shortfall actually half is due to the
vehicle program and half is due to the
general program so we look at the
vehicle program as is currently in the
capital
program then we've got
30 large refuse recycling super vehicles
and
27 roughly 27 medium and small vans
now the current cost to replace all of
those vehicles would run at about 4.7
million and have an average life of
around seven years
and that would give
that gives us an annual cost of about
675 000 and we currently contribute 555
000.
um so this this is just a graph to show
how that works and the reason why we
currently put in 500 slightly less is
that actually when we started this
this sort of
refresh of the vehicle program we
already had some money in reserves and
we also put in the sale of the three
depots when we get the new environmental
center so that means we already have
money to start with so we didn't need to
top up too much over the next years to
meet the next refresh
so we can
we can
refresh the
the major next refresh the vehicles in
2627 is fine but from then on we're not
putting in enough money
um to meet that same requirement in
32.33 and it would actually give us a
3.2 million
so
so the proposal therefore is to
which is already included in the budget
that david did is to increase
the
vehicles by 100 a year
up to 655 000 a year and then in
subsequent years increase it by
by inflation
and this generally roughly balances us
all the way to 32.33
so
with that recommendation that balances
our vehicle which is half of our
shortfall so the other half is the
general program
which is 177.
but in addition to that we have
additional pressures over the over the
next five years um
falling on queben's capital so although
we've got pids suggested for next year
um four years after that there obviously
isn't anything in at the moment so even
uh you know so even uh half of what has
been suggested this year about 5000 we
could be looking at another two million
there's also a linear defenses
work um
which we do in conjunction with
environmental agency and this is in
early stages to discussion but the early
estimates are that it's going to come in
at possibly three it could be three
million or more and
torrid would have
has to do some sort of contribution so
it could be it could be around the one
and a half million mark
um
[Music]
including some electric fans
actually
we've got
the bigger refuse vehicles where there's
no there's nothing on the market at the
moment
um
which meets the sort of climate
objectives and meets the nature of
torridge um
but we're fairly sure that there'll be
some sort of electric or hybrid vehicles
for the refuge coming in the future and
there's going to be an additional cost
to that
i've also got desktop strategy which is
uh counts with it infrastructure
um
so it runs to for the next five years it
runs to 2024 but actually the next
refresh um is estimated about 250
around all those pressures um future
pressures up at the moment then we could
be looking at
3.75 million is what we've got there
so
so then we've got a
small shortfall of 177 we've actually
got large future pressures of 3.75
million
so then it's really coming to
recommending the kids to full council
now
each of each of the pins needs to be
approved by full council um
so we need to consider each one um
[Music]
recommended
uh steve has already talked through a
bit of how it's scored so each each one
has a project score out of 100 and
there's a recommended minimum of 65.
there's also a financial score which is
to help compare the cost of
the kids amongst themselves at each
point each financial point recommends a
cost of about 100 grand to the council
so here's here's the list of um the new
bids and the relevant and the relative
scoring
so
we've got course fuel of course server
grounds maintenance
can stand paths because then there are
two
options for standard new road
which is a
an extensive repair of one an additional
parking place and a lower cost option
and we've also got the reference and
ben's digitization and they will score
from 87 65
and then we've got five projects which
were scored below the line the insurance
and player market um the two electric
bank hits
um victoria park player and william lane
so just in summary we've got current
short for 177 now that's with all the
new pits including the below the line
authorized
um however if we
do the recommendations which we've got
below
um this actually moves to a 460 000
pound surplus so we've got a little bit
of money for future um
future pits future pressures
um but it is in within the context of
possibly those future pressures of three
three million plus
so then the recommendations um for
members to consider to full council
is for the capital programme to be
updated for the building cost uh the
vehicle program to be updated for
inflation
and the vehicle program to be balanced
long-term increasing the contributions
for revenue
and
recommended
project score of 65 rebar included in
the program
that's
[Music]
um
i know
uh when we're determining our priorities
a great deal of thought is given to it
and everything
naturally becomes dear to your heart if
it affects your particular
area in which you live
however we do have to look at this for
torridge district and
the best use of
our resources
what i would like to point out is that
under uh in the recommendations d
it says
with the pids that fall below this door
being referred back to officers for
further work and refinement
and possible future consideration
this council accepted
a new system of scoring
and drew up the scheme that we have
followed or has been followed to
actually arrive at the stores for these
if
this is
suggested that it's not
um coming up with the results that would
be seen by this council as being the
right way to proceed we need to review
that system but we adopted this system
overview and scrutiny
determined how they were going to store
projects
so just because we don't like the
answers we can't just throw it out
without some careful examination
i would suggest that
we accept the recommendations of this
report
and mined that paragraph saying that we
have the potential
to go back
and look at pigs that have fallen
beneath
the
and
this is for us to consider whether the
pid scheme
ons recommended to full council and they
adopted
is working
so i would
recommend the proposals within this
report
and
draw everybody's attention to that
factor
okay okay
next
[Music]
did that take any consideration
the 55 000 pounds
that the bridge just and the town
council have collectively put into the
project
or is that this is 173 in addition no
it's included
so there is some grant
so the 173 is the total cost of the
project okay well that's slightly
misleading in in the fact that 173
doesn't there because it's not
necessarily 173 thousand forage money
no that's that's partly why we do the
financial score to try and um compare
them um
although there is rounded sort the
nearest hundred thousand might not stick
out as much in this
um
but
[Music]
[Music]
completely contrasting prices there
the ones not recommended to go forward
which is 213.
the 46 is clearly for
just repairs
now the situation in the real world is
very simple people used to wait
and let people come forward past each
other
they don't do that on sounding heroes
now it's a high speed although it's got
speed bumps people go for it
it's a single track road and you have to
leave it so your
your offside wheels are always going to
be on the grass and it's just created
a mouse
the repair money
is just fending off and i don't really
know myself and i know
it's in my wall so i should definitely
support it
but the 213 puts in additional lay-by
to stop people just going for it
so
i i just wonder whether that one
really should be above the line at the
moment
because it is just
preparing something that is just going
to be worn out today and you're still
going to be faced with the 230 future
ice machine i know it's a separate
gender item but on page 28 it is
included in the pit but on the chart on
page 32 it's neither there below or
above the moment so i just wonder
had to include it for the budget into
the program but i think it's going as a
separate report to full council tonight
um
due mainly because that's included in
this year's capital program due to the
funding
deadlines basically
so i think if you're counseling that
will decide on that pit tonight
thank you for having me
is with regard to the contribution
from a bit of a town council and
the bridge trust regarding victoria park
when we were
looking at the report and preparing this
um
the sum of 51 000 plans have been
alluded to
at council
um when i believe in reality this is not
such a great amount that there is not
this total sum being given by bridge
the british trust and benefit town
council i believe that yeah
that's why i've got councillor christie
i'm sitting here
not the other way around
um but i do believe and i would like
this clarified because i believe
officers did explore
exactly what was available in grant
funding
and i was led to believe this was
considerably less that's point one so
that is a question um
and we need that clearly stated so
everybody understands exactly what is on
the table
the issue around san diego road if we do
nothing um about repairing this
this council becomes liable for all
sorts of issues if uh cars and vehicles
are damaged so we do have to maintain
things to a certain level
but i will leave aside but uh can we
please have some clarification on the
amount available towards this pit
from
both sources please
right um do you want to speak i can
clarify that point for everything
so peter you got paid in front of you
from memory there is 51 000 pounds
available for play in biddeford from a
combined uh contribution of the uh
bridge trust and tank council but it's
not all available to the victoria park
project so we kind of clarified i think
there's ten thousand pounds from each of
those organizations is the contribution
to this project that's that's that's the
time clock performance
right councillor krusty was the next one
to speak anyway so thank you i will just
explain that um
two and a half years ago uh i got 25 000
pounds from the town council 25 000
pounds of the british trust
towards new play equipment in business
um since then uh
torridge
has spent some of it
they spent some of the british trust
money
so the british trust still had 19 000
odd and there's 25 000 still from the
town council uh we're also on the
british house we've also supplied um we
were offered over 7 000 pounds towards
flood lighting
skateboard park
but given the problems of the risen
skateboard park we thought we assumed
that these uh floodlighting will not go
ahead
and uh i asked the british trust and
they've now allocated the 7 000 into
this summer money it's 51 000 now
available
of that money the 25 000 pounds in
british russia is still available as far
as i know from victoria park plus the
seven thousand
on the town council they voted ten
thousand towards victoria park and the
rest go to smaller areas but of course
that's still subsidizing storage uh so
you know the money you might have spent
on smaller areas can go for a part so
there is 51 000
but um the reason i put my hand up was a
couple of other things actually i hope
that clears it up anyway um
on page 31
again i see linear defenses at westwood
hove
one and a half millions the biggest
single thing there and we seem to be
drifting along with this
um there are some of us who
consider those houses just behind
westwood
uh behind the pebble which should never
be built there in the first place and i
feel very strongly we're not here to
defend houses it shouldn't be there the
reason we need to look at this linear
defense
we need to look at the whole defense of
the pebble ridge
because that's our one tourist beach
that's what we should be looking at not
to defend a few houses it shouldn't be
there and i i every time i see this
people we see you just kind of drifting
along oh yeah one last minute no problem
where are we going to find that and i
think we need to have a really serious
look at that the other thing i'd like to
bring up is the sandy mirror road and i
agree with council of laws
uh in the past you'd drive along and uh
you'd stop
now
a couple of things here i seem to
remember when i was on the asset
management group
you chairman that uh
andrew weight i think spent three
hundred thousand pounds on sandy mirror
that's the bigger that sticks in my mind
and i'm just astonished we've got a
repair already because i went down there
on the go it looked alright to me
and
i i really think we shouldn't be
spending any money on sand me a road
because
one of the problems is everyone's cars
got bigger
um
you go along now you've got these huge
four by four things driving around um
and that's one of the problems i i don't
think it's hard duty to put another lay
by and repair it i really don't and i'd
like us to actually take out sandy
mirror this time and perhaps
boost up the electric bands we've got
two electric bands there 24 000.
i'd like them to go above the line
because we have got
the climate change emergency we've
declared
and yet here we are the one road we
control we're going to spend money on
the electric cars we're not going to
it's in the complete inversion of our
priorities there
councillor brandon
thank you chair well let's continue with
the theme of san andrea road um i've
been misfortuned to have to use it
during the summer with grandsons in the
busy times and it's an absolute
nightmare that brothers i wouldn't spend
another penny on it it was designed
badly in the first place never dreamed
that up didn't have any clue as to how
tourists operate in busy times
the lay guys are a waste of time people
weren't using them at all one or two
but most people were just taking the
risk of passing one another as council
christie pointed out everybody buys uh
drives around chelsea tractors now god
knows why but nonetheless uh there are
tight squeeze to go along there we need
to really look at this asset that we've
got there we've got a new center there
now we haven't still
manned the gateways manually manually
you know why
because council laws are pointing out
earlier on we're losing revenue in the
evenings because locals go down there
late at night when they don't pay
why we haven't automated that system i
don't know i can't think of another car
park that i've been to recently you know
i've been to various places in the
southwest
that's got a system like we have it
doesn't make sense but the road if
you're going to do a proper road let do
it
right you know it needs these days it's
going to be too late unless you're going
to have a one-way system which you could
do around the uh
that borough's end but at the moment it
certainly doesn't work
oh and the other thing i've noticed that
in this instance is it right then that
the
over two hundred thousand pounds being
spent really on the core server i
produced technology and so is the reds
and benz that is that technology as well
is it that's technology yeah that's that
sort of sums up society really doesn't
that's the priority in life technology
you can't beat it
right i i've got one comment from the
chair no one's mentioned
and that's tori cameo
um
this is a listed building
two star
we are the planning authority we've got
people running around giving people
rockets for not maintaining listed
buildings and whatever and whatever
yeah here we are with one of our center
we've got the money we can't afford to
do it
it's not on we've got a listed building
for which we've got responsibility
whether we'd like it or not we've got to
be dealt with the same as the general
public and told you we'll find the money
there we are clicks the break
thank you sure yeah i was also going to
bring up that as well um because we're
going to pay your
remember that two years ago i submitted
a notice of motion to do repairs on
building and eventually it first got
passed then it got reviewed through the
project review and it got refused at
that point
and then less than three months later
emoji would repair what's had to go on
because the bell tower wasn't falling
off
so it seems like
we cut the budget down but actually
still need to spend money doing the work
anyway and i feel at the same point now
there have been uh preliminary um
investigations into different parts of
the building so they placed paint off
around the windows and around
the
yeah it's made it look worse right now
but if we're not going to do the works
then it's just going to be left looking
even worse than it was when we started
um
and there are only you know three main
buildings in the town square that
you know you think of torrington that's
the first three things you think of
the globe
uh the town hall
and market house
and
the globe is also in the state we were
looking at that but the
penny market market house i don't really
understand why such a
focal asset is so
ignored essentially
counselor bushman
[Music]
i'd support that
and furthermore i'd like the the savings
identified to be able to move victoria
park
play direct and turn the party market as
you've alluded to above the red line
in favor of signing the road
in a sense because
here is a bit of treasure our market our
opinion market is great
and many years ago when councilor
brenton was mayor last
um the town council took it over we got
a golden handshake
from torridge
and we actually applied for the grants
we did all the work and we still look
after it and it costs porridge nothing
now
um and i find it
popping up doesn't it repairs here
repairs there i think we should actually
approach times and town camps and say
look
we give you a silver handshake or
whatever you take it on because
otherwise
it's a drain on us and yet it seems a
bit unfair here in biddeford we look
after our own family market
feeling i have regularly on this capsule
as far as my award is concerned comes
from christine but black cats were lost
man yes um
[Music]
be legal consequences but we just have
to look again but i can't understand how
you can
balance your budget here how you can
look at victoria carl
and uh
torrington and
[Music]
[Music]
harvey
thank you chair at the uh the paid
workshop
councilman voted
what we see in front of us today
sandy mare road was the cheaper option
was chosen because we're trying to
balance the
budget as council laws just said if you
stop around some of these things here
it's going to be a nightmare to be
honest trying to get the extra money and
i believe the worker talking about
working good looking at that in more
detail but this was the um
these were the kids that were acceptable
to the council that attended the
pitt workshop
councillor homes
thank you chairman
thank you for letting me speak um
yeah just i think it's been um stated
today that we are
committed to a climate um emergency and
net zero by 230 as a council
and you may remember that thomas sibley
came to this committee and presented the
results of her carbon audit
and she did the pie chart and if you
look to that pie chart i think
over 50
of this council's um emissions to do
with its buildings and its activities
over 50 percent
relates to transport direct and indirect
um therefore
um my concern was immediate when i
looked at the
selection for the pids and the fact that
uh
the ev bands uh projects are below 65
percent
um it's been stated just now that we had
when we had our kids meeting that we
voted um for this ranking um i can't
actually did we actually vote i remember
a discussion which
covered a whole range of issues some of
which
conclusions weren't that clear
[Music]
when we voted i'm not quite sure but i'm
concerned about the scoring and just
like to
refer to a couple of councillors and
their two or three councillors their
concerns about san diego road
and if we are prioritizing
then san diego it seems to be giving a
signal that we're encouraging car use um
and we're downgrading the eevs
i'm not quite sure what the situation is
with these former presentation
maybe we can have a little bit of extra
clarification about how we're going to
progress on
investing in those um i should say that
evs
i know that certain counsellors think
that evs are too
infant in their technology i should
point out that our one of our
other devon councils east devon has had
a fleet of ev vans since 2020 on the
least police on basis
um
referring to
the statistics in this country there's
been
a significant increase in ev purchase if
you want to go further
in the rest of the world norway now has
only two point something percent of
diesels in its uh car ownership it's
such a massive turnover to leaves
because um in terms of assessing
the costs involved in the evs
you have to look at the whole life
context of the maintenance the lower
maintenance and running costs which i
hope i'm sure
richard hastings and charlotte wallace
has been doing
but
i do implore you to
um
consider again sandy mirror 200 000 on
that road when i think as council
christie said we spent three hundred
thousand on roads
on the boroughs only a few years five
years six years ago was it
um
it just seems wrong to me it's it's
putting out the wrong signal it's
i don't know it's encouraging more
people
to have an impact on the biodiversity of
the barriers which i think should be a
huge consideration
how you deal with a
increase of traffic that's likely to
come on the barrows and i realize it's
an income generator but you have to
weigh up all the other factors i mean
perhaps we should look at a road that
goes along with federal reach of some
sort of slightly better surface i don't
know but it's just it's just gearing the
wrong signal and i hope that you would
um consider
recommending putting the ev um
projects um above the line and taking
out
possibly looking at
torrington market
why
you know why it's the case benefit
market the south molten market will be
run by town councils
in the long term with a bit of help and
financial help from this council i can't
torrent
market be run by its own council um
by the time council
so
yeah that that's that's my concern maybe
we have a bit more clarification about
um you know what
what the plan is for evs over the next
few years we've got until 2030 and we
i think the public is expecting us
you know to step by our commitments
i've been asked to talk to a meeting
next week about what torridge is doing i
don't want to say that we're going for
diesel instead of evs thanks very much
just a final small point
the implications on the uh certain
implications the end of the report
there's nothing um about the climate
implications or the biodiversity
applications i just wonder why
okay thanks
climate and diversity wonder why
is there an answer to that one climate
which was a recommendation made by
internal uh overall treatment i think
council hedge proposed that
recommendation at the time of internal
scrutiny so that was accepted into the
each individual bid document
councillor bride
thank you chad i just like to comment on
the comments uh uh several councils are
making about torrington town council
taking over the tangent market
i mean i can't say whether you can
handle would be willing to or not
um take that over but there's two things
that you should probably be aware of on
that is that
a great time town council has less
residence in its area therefore the
income from council taxes is less so it
has that purchasing power certainly a
factor on that and second thing is they
would probably only consider buying it
if it was repaired up to standard in the
first place
chair um the leader and i have uh have a
meeting scheduled with the uh town mayor
and clark
in the next couple of weeks i can't
believe members wishes to explore
[Music]
[Music]
after hearing the same old trunk being
banned about electric vehicles
councillor haines heard
when we were considering the pits the
reasons why
for the time being it's not proven to go
down the electric van
vehicles
we've got one and it's it's not been a
success for touring but i keep hearing
the same thing all the time and 2030
being mentioned
as if what torridge does in the club in
the carbon reduction state is going to
make once
judging difference to the world
but that's bad about it i'll go back to
what councillor hudson said at the start
we we've agreed a way of
judging the pits that we've looked at
and this is what we've come up with and
i hear about 70 new rules
we thought it was ridiculous to talk
about spending 230 odd thousand on
another day by and the work on somebody
the other one was a smaller figure for
repairs
but it needs to be kept up in a repaired
state
i drive down 70 year old regular battery
and i've never seen people tear arsenal
down that road i really haven't and you
can pass it
easily
and there are two passing plays you know
that people don't use i don't know all
the fuss is about sending the world
14 000 for repairs otherwise let it go
to rock and roll and cost you even more
but
the basic thing is all these kids have
been assessed
by the criteria that we set as a council
to judge the bids by its council
[Music]
they stand so i am prepared to second
that as they stand
i think to be just too complicated at
this late stage to start changing them
councillor hodgson
yeah uh thank you councillor um i did
want to emphasize the um
clause that is underneath the proposed
pits that we have this capacity so we
accept
to actually review and look at the pits
again as a fall underneath the score so
i think that's important as a point of
information there has been um
when when we're talking about sandy mia
because the
dear to my heart it's on my doorstep as
well
um the the potential for having
maybe a one-way system to alleviate
problems but
we then run in as a local authority to
the challenge of natural england and the
road that runs along the back of the
ridge
and the likelihood of us being able to
make that into they've refused as having
a tarmac surface so it's just a i don't
know
pressed
uh stuff
um and if we made that the the one-way
system we really would be in trouble
very quickly i think with potholes with
cars going up and down there
so we tried to find a workable solution
half of it is road etiquette
and people driving
and their you know their concerns
councillor leather says has no problems
but in the summer it can be very
difficult because people are
inconsiderate and they always think
they're bigger and better than everybody
else and want to get there faster
i do think we need to do keep it up to a
fit state of repair
and um you know i just wanted to make
sure that everybody realized that we
have looked at that other road
or
and
taken that into consideration but it's
not feasible
as we speak
so thank you we just wanted to clear
that up and i would like it noted that
we need to be really clear about the
um voluntary contributions that go
towards the victoria park play area and
i appreciate what councilman christie
has informed this committee again
but i need to be reassured because uh
the information i was given relayed by
the town clerk didn't quite
reflect the town class position and the
town council
so thank you
all right
you wanted to speak yes um i'll go back
to my original proposition um
i think there's been a slightly
different one since then my proposal was
that we take out sandy mirror altogether
and i quite agree with councillor about
the road
um
[Music]
if we take that out forty six thousand
but i would like the two electric cars
put in at twenty four thousand so we're
actually saving twenty two thousand
i don't think we can
put it towards uh torrington market or
victoria park because they're both
around 170 odd thousand and it's not
going to make a lot of difference
uh to putting it above the thing there
whereas if we take
sandy mirror out we can actually replace
it with something else without
disturbing everything else and that was
my original proposition i don't know if
i've got a second bit for that
[Music]
one has to be taken first doesn't it
yeah but
there are two schools of thought here
one is to accept this as rich
the other is to make amendments to that
which is written
first of all i'm going to put it as it's
proposed and seconded as written
if you don't agree will you vote against
quite simple
and if there is a majority against
then we'll have to look at each
individual item and take a vote on it
but remember it's recorded folks all the
way through today
you don't need a recorded vote just
setting the council taxes
oh right i don't need to record it but
thank you right anyway i'm gonna put
the formal motion
to you
those in favor of the recommendations
1.9 top to bottom
please show
one two three four five one
six
those against
one two three four
five
so the answer is it's accepted as
printed and that's what goes to full
count
okay
i think that deals with the agenda
oh
i to make sorry
the recommendation from external
overview and scrutiny
that there be an uplift in the graph to
citizens advice from 38 to 50 000 in the
next financial year
um councillor hodgson
um
yes
regrettably i wasn't able to attend the
community
the
sorry the overview and scrutiny
meeting
when this was proposed
the
it was proposed from the
council members
to increase this in recognition and i
understand and empathize with the
rationale behind it but it was proposed
at a meeting where there was no report
there was no knowledge of how much
we were actually funding citizens advice
and it was just to increase it to 50 000
without any consideration
um from where it came
so i would like to suggest this goes
back
so that we get a full report on this
with the options of additional
assistance for
um citizen's advice being considered
one of the things that i have thought
about is that
uh the
members who represent the area that uh
benefits citizens of weiburria
peoria
bureau
serve
um northern epidural westwood
biddeford
um
maybe a little bit further out for
people
the members all have counsellor grants
and at the moment we stand at 58 000
pounds unspent grant this year
so one could think that the 12 000 pound
shortfall could be quite easily made up
from councilman grant
without putting any further pressures on
our revenue budget
and i'd like to propose this goes to um
back to overview and scrutiny to
consider it with a full report
i know what you say but surely
if we're in disagreement with ons that's
the point when it goes to full council
not referred back doesn't it
so this one we can throw it back up
okay right i have a proposal
anyone else wishing to speak
counselling only briefly checkers
i am a member of that old viewers
currently committed and heard the
presentation from
the cab which of course just doesn't
just cover
the town's encouragement council hudson
and old torridge
he also covers north devon western mid
game so there are four
cat district councils involved and i
quite accept that we'd like a bit more
information
but
really when you think about it what
we've heard this morning about the
increased massive increase
in planning income massive increase in
northern burials this summer
a minus only 12 000 extra on the 38th we
currently give them would seem to be
well within reach from whatever budget
there must be a budget there we could
find that problem but some of the
figures that
were given at that meeting with the sk
they are a huge financial benefit within
what they do
i think for every pound
that's invested in them in grants they
get about 27 pounds back in benefit and
i'll just give you one figure and i'll
leave it then
2021 a staggering 7.6 million of income
gain was awarded through work that the
cab had done so
yeah send it back to
to look at it but i'd be very surprised
if it was cancelled that the end will
not increase by a 12 phone
thanks john thanks for that
anyone else wishing to speak
yes
yeah i just um go forward with a little
bit of trepidation you're right the cab
do a great job and they cover
um the towns and they also cover the
rural areas but
um certainly one particular
area i'm aware of within my ward
they they do apply to all parishes the
um outline parishes for funding as well
which invariably
they do get um
my question would be and then again i
did not attend
overview in scrutiny so i would very
much like a report to come back
how wisely they spend their money
because i know there was an appeal for a
laptop so they could provide an outreach
service to a particular outlying area
and when it came to that service was
never provided even though the money was
given
um and in fact it fell short um so you
know i really like confirmation that the
money is used to
to sensible um benefit of the local
community as opposed to just
admin or whatever else
is normally the way these things are
going
so yeah i definitely support the report
coming back
with more information
okay i've got no one else wishing to
speak i've got a proposal in the
secondary
but the matter be referred back to
overview and scrutiny really more
information for more details as i
understand it
um those in favor please show
that is
unanimous
well that's clear my apologies for
trying to draw the meeting to a close
earlier but i can do so now
and thank you all for your attendance as
we close the meeting up
11 foot